We're finally in the endgame now.
Following the world premiere of Avengers:
Endgame on Monday, April 22nd in downtown
Los Angeles, Marvel Studios lifted the social
media embargo on first reactions to the superhero
epic — spoiler-free, of course.
Those fortunate enough to attend the screening
ahead of the film's theatrical debut later
this week raced to Twitter to pour out praise
by the bucketful, with critics, journalists,
and members of the media lionizing it as the
perfect culmination of the last 11 years of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
One common thread?
This movie is gonna make you cry like crazy.
"This is a hot, hot movie.
I didn't see the ending because I was crying
too much.
I give it three hot, wet kisses."
Mashable's Angie J. Han, who admitted she
wasn't much of a fan of Infinity War, wrote
that Endgame is, quote, "an immensely satisfying
payoff, not just to Infinity War but to all
the films that came before (it)."
Brandon Davis of ComicBook.com had powerful
words to offer regarding Avengers: Endgame.
He tweeted, "#AvengersEndgame is an astonishing,
amazing film.
I've never seen anything like it.
This movie is everything I wanted to be and
SO much more.
Amazing … While watching #AvengersEndgame,
I laughed so loud, I clapped with so much
force, and I cried so hard.
The movie exceeds every expectation and is
the perfect culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe."
Fandango managing editor Erik Davis also noted
that Endgame is a flawless, intelligent coming-together
of the 21 films that preceded it, further
teasing that the flick's ending is a rousing
one.
"#AvengersEndgame is a masterful epic — a
true culmination of 22 films that not only
concludes the story, but expands upon it.
You'll learn more about the other movies while
this one unfolds.
If Infinity War is the brawn, Endgame is the
brains.
And wow, what an ending!"
He added in follow-up tweets that Endgame
stands as its own entity that complements
Infinity War, even though the two films were
shot back-to-back and do deal with the same
major threat in the intergalactic tyrant Thanos.
Meanwhile, audiences should be ready to check
their pride at the door and prepare to bawl
their eyes out and laugh hysterically while
watching Endgame unfold.
"Do not go in expecting Infinity War part
two.
The two films are so different, yet compliment
[sic] each other in all the best ways.
In terms of which MCU movie to watch beforehand…
honestly, all of them.
What an experience — what an accomplishment."
"Not going to spoil anything at all, but I
will say I laughed, I cried, I cried, I cheered,
I laughed, I cried again and then the entire
audience gave it a massive standing ovation.
And then I cried again.
Be ready, kids.
Be.
Ready.
#AvengersEndgame."
Peter Sciretta of Slashfilm tweeted that Avengers:
Endgame is incredibly emotional, apparently
due to both what happens within the film and
what the movie means to the larger picture
of the MCU.
"Imagine the best possible version of #AvengersEndgame
and somehow the film still surpasses all expectations.
I cried 5-6 times.
It's the most emotional, most epic, MCU film.
A tribute to ten years of this universe and
holy shit the great fan service in this movie.
Soooo good."
Movie Trivia Shmoedown creator Kristian Harloff
agreed, writing, "Man #AvengersEndgame kicked
my ass.
It was an epic conclusion to 11 years of films.
It had laughs, incredible action and absolute
emotional rollercoaster.
It was the series finale for (this) cast of
characters that I had been hoping for.
Congrats to all for pulling off the feat."
Beatrice Verhoeven, senior film reporter at
The Wrap, had something surprising to say
to fans: none of the theories they came up
with have braced them for Endgame.
"So I just saw #AvengersEndgame, and you guys
aren't ready for s***.
All the theorizing didn't prepare you for
this.
I cried a lot, I flung my hands in the air
and screamed out loud.
It's incredible."
Dave Itzkoff of the New York Times was so
emotionally involved in the film that he wound
up questioning his own parentage.
"I was not prepared for the range of emotions
that #Endgame put me through, from utter despair
to pure elation.
I laughed, I cried, I wished Tony Stark was
my dad."
Let's quickly check in with Tony Stark to
see how he feels about that.
Dennis Tzeng of Collider Video praised Avengers:
Endgame as, quote, "an achievement in blockbuster
filmmaking," and said, "#AvengersEndgame is
filled with so much comic book awesomeness
that you may not be ready!"
Of course, not everyone completely freaked
the hell out on Twitter.
Variety's Matt Donnelly kept his reaction
to Endgame simple but impactful: "Incredible
ingenuity and commitment.
Marvel and Disney can and should be proud
of this moment."
Aaron Crouch of The Hollywood Reporter added
to the chorus of people singing Endgame's
praises noting that most of what fans have
seen of the film thus far through trailers
and TV spots barely scratches the surface
of the full flick: "90 % of the #AvengersEndgame
footage that's been officially released is
from the first 15 minutes: Other than the
actual surprises, the biggest surprise to
me was how funny it is."
CinemaBlend's Eric Eisenberg offered a response
to Endgame that will give you chills: "This
can't be understated: #AvengersEndgame is
everything you want it to be and more.
I am absolutely floored.
A perfect reflection on the last 11 years
that pays off everything in the best way possible.
Without question my new favorite Marvel Cinematic
Universe film.
Stunned."
Perri Nemiroff of Collider had a similar reaction,
though she warned that Endgame does, at times,
feel overwhelming.
In all, Nemiroff feels that everything leading
up to the film and to the film's conclusion
was worth it: "#AvengersEndgame is A LOT.
Too much at times.
But wow the payoff is huge.
Left me proud to have invested over a decade
in a franchise that delivers an inspiring
exploration of what it means to be family
& a hero.
(Endgame also now has one of my favorite shots
in the entire MCU.)"
Hmmm...really?
Better than this shot?
Or this shot?
Overall, response to Avengers: Endgame has
been overwhelmingly positive.
Critics have called it everything from the
"greatest superhero movie EVER" to "entertainment
from beginning to end" to "the film of the
year."
As always, though, these are just a selection
of reactions to a film that everyone is bound
to have different opinions about.
The fantastic feedback should make fans giddy
as they await the premiere of Avengers: Endgame
on Friday, April 26, when they'll have the
chance to offer their own thoughts on the
superhero epic.
Until then, sit tight and avoid spoilers.
And when the time comes, as one critic advised,
"plan your bathroom breaks accordingly."
And whatever you do...don't be like Iron Man.
"You know the question I get asked most often
is Tony, how do you go to the bathroom in
the suit...
just like that."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.